[Music]  you began as a stand-up is that right  very young age how did that happen  um I was kind of obsessed with comedy it  was a super young age as you said and  any time I had the chance to perform I  try and do it do a tight ten somewhere  so like show and tell  I'd be like could I do some stand-up but  I was what show-and-tell in school so  other kids are showing like this is that  this is the thing that holds the towel  roll in our house but it was mostly like  I would watch sets of like Whoopi  Goldberg and do things that were wildly  inappropriate that I didn't really  understand like Whoopi Goldberg had this  character where she was like pointing at  her crotch would be like oh yeah  and so at seven I was going to school  and doing a whole set of back oh hey my  teacher would call my mom be like your  daughter has to stop pointing at her  crotch and inviting people to it yeah  there were so many things going wrong